[Musique]
il ne fait pour moi aucun doute que ces
hémoglobine marine de verre animale
seront utilisés ou ont déjà été utilisés
mc louzine ce qui est un spécialiste du
dopage sanguin dans le monde du sport il
publie régulièrement ses recherches dans
le magazine sport et vie il a constaté
récemment que la découverte de franck
zal aurait fait son apparition dans
certaines compétitions sportives à la
peut-être était utilisée dès les
championnats de monde de ski de fond de
ces fêtes en 2019 le réseau du docteur
march mixte a donc pu opérer en toute
quiétude pendant plusieurs années cette
hémoglobine de vers marins et
lyophilisée c'est à dire des cités par
le froid séché par le froid et donc en
poudre il suffit de la dissoudre don du
sérum physiologique et de l'injecter en
intraveineuse
la conservation à température ambiante
plusieurs années
bon une poche de sang c'est six à sept
semaines
quelques degrés donc c'est un produit
très sûr on sait aujourd'hui que le
dopage sanguin est de plus en plus
utilisé dans le sport de haut niveau car
il permet d'avoir une plus grande
quantité d'oxygène dans l'organisme
durant l'effort imaginons maintenant
quarante fois plus d'oxygène grâce au
ver marin un nouveau dopage sportif
indétectable est il en train de naître
les thèses détection pour l'hémoglobine
de vers marins l'art et nicolas marina
ou autre espèce de verre est au point
mais
le test de détection ne permet le
contrôle à quelques heures par exemple
dans un grand tour si un tour de france
n'est pas contrôlée de 23h à 6h le
dopage avec cette nouvelle hémoglobine
animal soluble être entièrement possible
alors elle est à toxic
immunogène cette durée de vie est de 2,5
jours elle transporte 40 fois plus
d'oxygène que l'hémoglobine humaine tout
en étant deux cent cinquante fois plus
petites dont on peut imaginer tout de
suite que des microdoses
suffirait à faire la différence
et seraient indétectables
pascal chez certains produits et
d'autant bien évidemment mais dès le
démarrage nous on le savait parce qu'en
fait quand on apporte beaucoup plus
d'oxygène on sait qu'on a un peu un
métabolisme beaucoup plus poussée donc
dès le démarrage on a travaillé avec
l'association française de lutte
antidopage donc on leur a donné notre
produit pour qu'ils mettent en place en
fait des tests donc savoir comment le
détecter en fait dans du sang de
patients ou de cyclistes etc il ya un
côté positif c'est de sauver des gens le
côté négatif c'est d'utiliser cette
technologie dans d'autres buts mais ça
c'est pas la faute de la science en fait
la science en fait elle veut juste
découvrir d'écrire et c'est
l'augmentation du transport de l'oxygène
c'est la tentation de certains athlètes
de haut niveau
dans les années 2000 le monde du sport
va être gangréné par les p o de synthèse
plus connu sous le nom médical de l'est
presque
pouvait faire en fait de le payer pour
avoir un taux de globules rouges plus
important dans le sang des patients
d'autres qui vont dire bah ouais c'est
super je peux avoir un taux
d'hématocrite plus important donc c'est
toujours les doubles faces en fait vu de
la science pour mieux contrôler les
variations sanguine chez les athlètes de
haut niveau les instances de
l'antidopage vont créer le passeport
sanguin qui va permettre de déceler si
ces variations sont suspectes pour marc
claudine ski l'arrivée de cette nouvelle
et maghrébine marine va pouvoir
complètement contourner le passeport
sanguin il fallait donc on tourner
l'outil du passeport sanguin qui
s'intéressent à ce qui se passe dans un
groupe b le rouge or ces hémoglobine de
vers marins permet d'apporter de
l'hémoglobine mais en dehors du
compartiment globulaires donc le
passeport sanguin est tout à fait court
circuiter
l'amélioration de la performance en se
dopant à l'épée aux de synthèse n'est
plus à prouver le cyclisme et le ski de
fond sont deux sports qui ont été
friands de ce type de dopage
l'hémoglobine du ver marin découverte
par la société i marina suscite déjà des
convoitises dans le milieu sportif on
est contacté en fait régulièrement en
fait donc par des sportifs par des
salles de sport par des gens qui savent
que cette molécule peut être dopantes
mais c'est assez incroyable parce qu'en
fait on se dit soyons complètement idiot
soit ils nous prennent pour des idiots
parce que en fait il y en a qui donne
même le renom qui disent voilà donc on
est là on voudrait avoir comme monstres
comme on achète votre produit je vous en
achète etc etc le père je dirais que
c'est c'est un peu compliqué alors que
là en fait cette molécule elle est
quasiment identique à vos globules
rouges au micro dos est difficilement
détectable et c'est sûr que je comprends
très bien la trêve pourrait alors cette
molécule pour les pour les sportifs en
particulier sportif de haut niveau c'est
clair que cette molécule elle pourrait
avoir des impacts majeurs sur les
performances musculaires c'est sûr que
si vous avez un transporteurs d'oxygène
qui peut nous apporter beaucoup plus
d'oxygène que votre propre hémoglobine
après il y aura des tas de questions qui
se posent derrière quelle est la durée
de vie du produit dans l'organisme est
ce qu'il faudrait injecter souvent
qu'est ce que ça pourrait induire comme
conséquence aussi si vous en prenez trop
je ne sais pas donc tous à ccc des
domaines aussi qu'ils sont complètement
inconnu
[Musique]
nous en fait on publie en fait ce qui
est des publiées dans les journaux
scientifiques à comité de lecture
quelqu'un qui a fait de la science qui
sait ce que c'est la biochimie la
physiologie respiratoire
qui sait extraire des protéines purifier
des protéines bah vous voyez ces livres
en fête vous pouvez aller chercher des
verts sur la plage
je ne comprendrais pas pourquoi elles ne
seraient pas utilisés si elle ne l'est
pas déjà
c'est le graal du dopage sanguin le
monde du dopage sportif a toujours suivi
de près les avancées de la science en
les détournant à son profit avec les
incroyables bénéfices oxygénant du ver
marin on peut se demander quels seront
les performances de demain
les autorités mondiales de l'antidopage
devront intervenir rapidement si on ne
veut pas que le vert s'installe
définitivement dans la pomme
[Musique]